le Sénat et la seconde chambre du
Parlement français aujourd'hui il
partage avec l'Assemblée nationale le
pouvoir législatif mais cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas au fil des époques
et selon les régimes qui ont marqué
l'histoire de France la forme et les
fonctions du Sénat ont évolué et c'est
ce que nous allons vous raconter
tout commence en 1794 ou plus exactement
en l'an 3 la tyrannie des
révolutionnaires a marqué les esprits
afin d'éviter les excès d'une assemblée
unique on décide de créer une seconde
chambre c'est le conseil des anciens il
est chargé d'adopter ou de rejeter les
lois proposées par le Conseil des 500
l'ancêtre de l'Assemblée nationale le
Conseil des Anciens siège ou Tuileries
jusqu'à sa suppression le lendemain du
18 brumaire en 8 c'est-à-dire en 1799
c'est avec Napoléon Bonaparte qui est
inscrit pour la première fois dans la
Constitution le terme de Sénat en
référence au Sénat romain antique
alors Premier consul Napoléon fait de
son Sénat conservateur un point clé du
régime chargé de veiller au respect de
la Constitution et de sélectionner les
membres des autres assemblées il ne
possède pas de pouvoir législatif mais
peut régler tout ce qui n'est pas prévu
par la Constitution par des Sénatus
consultés comme ceux du 18 mai 1804 et
du 1er avril 1814 qui proclame et met
fin au Premier Empire vient ensuite la
restauration monarchique qui installe en
1814 la chambre des pères de France
constituée de nobles et de notables
nommés par la couronne
ils prennent pas au pouvoir législatif
au même titre que le roi et la Chambre
des députés cette chambre perdure
jusqu'à la fin de la monarchie de
Juillet en 1848
puis le scénario vient avec Napoléon III
c'est un sénat conservateur composé de
militaires et de fidèles mais vers la
fin du Second Empire il acquiert
davantage de droit et de pouvoir après
l'épisode de la commune la Troisième
République installe en 1875 un sénat
véritablement républicain c'est durant
cette période que siège de fortes
personnalités Victor Schoelcher Victor
Hugo Jules Ferry Georges Clémenceau sans
oublier les présidentes du Sénat qui
accèdent à l'Élysée Émile Loubet Armand
Fayer Gaston doumerg Paul Doumer et
Albert Lebrun la Troisième République
c'est le temps de la toute-puissance
parlementaire le Sénat joue pleinement
son rôle jusqu'en 1940 la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale voit naître le
Conseil de la République en 1946 il
siège au Palais du Luxembourg sous la
présidence attentive et forte de Gaston
Monnerville ce conseil initialement son
grand pouvoir reprend au fil du temps
une partie des droits et prérogatives de
l'ancien Sénat
en 1954 il récupère l'initiative de la
loi et la navette est rétablie enfin la
Constitution de 1958 consacre le rôle de
colle législateur et de contre-pouvoirs
du Sénat un équilibre est trouvé entre
la volonté de créer un contrepoids à
l'Assemblée nationale et la nécessité de
surmonter les désaccords entre les deux
champs les sénateurs sont élus pour
Amanda plus long et par un collège
électoral composé essentiellement des
locaux en cas de désaccord avec
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
peut donner le dernier mot aux député
sauf dans certaines matières très
sensibles comme les révisions
constitutionnelles le président du Sénat
devient le deuxième personnage de l'État
à cette époque les présidents Gaston
monerville et Alain Poher n'hésite pas à
tenir tête au général de Gaulle
notamment sur l'élection du Président de
la République au suffrage universel la
régionalisation ou le référendum de 1969
va également assurer l'intérim de la
présidence de la République à deux
reprises en 1969 puis en 1974 c'est
aussi pendant cette période que la
mission de contrôle du Sénat se
développe avec la création d'une
première délégation parlementaire en
1972 et l'essor de commission d'enquêtes
et de travaux de contrôle qui abordent
des thèmes intéressants le grand public
le nucléaire les écoutes téléphoniques
ou encore la qualité des constructions
scolaires depuis le Sénat a cessé de
développer sa mission de contrôle du
gouvernement et d'évaluation des
politiques publiques chargées de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales il accompagne en parallèle
les progrès de la décentralisation et
soutient les élus locaux dans leur
mission alors que le passage du
septennat au quinquennat a conduit à une
synchronisation des élections
présidentielles et législatives le Sénat
joue plus que jamais un rôle essentiel
de contre-pouvoir en étant renouvelé par
moitié tous les trois ans